that's not how he sounds you got Batman
Jesus Luke oh that is way better no
father
oh you have not known how long I've been
wanting to taste the blue milk that's
how they drink in the damn universe Oh
Yoda done I think a lightsaber cheers I
believe look hmm
link doesn't taste like anything it
looks like Lucky Charms but it tastes
like fruitlets which is like chipping me
out oh god there's like so much sugar in
this is amazing
do you like jails I feel like this is
what Jedi's have to eat so they stay
energized during battle let's give it a
shot
oh my god that's delightful
I love it hmm no Jedi seemed pretty fit
like obi-wan seem like a stud back in
the day in Episode one I don't think he
was eating these Furyk in the lunchroom
I'll give you c-3po how do you do I
trade you my Yoda I got a bunch at UNC
Derby oh yeah take a seat creepy oh how
the EU Yoda
is this a lightsaber not a series of it
oh my god I've got a huge nerd boner
that was great one of this is what like
the Jedi's go through and they think of
it now we go to assembly oh this is not
good no it isn't after all that work it
should taste like something right what's
your flavor I feel like my flavor is
just sugar I feel like it would taste
better if it had like a little bit of
the sourness but this is just
straight-up sweet you know what a
learning curve I think I'm done this is
not for eating this is for play only
my god was so happy I need this in my
life
I could almost cry right now yeah she's
wearing the full Groucho Marx to avoid
copyright issues oh my god it's already
my new favorite beer I don't even have
to try it it smells delicious it does
let's just say that all right Cheers
that is so good I think I love it yeah
it's like coffee mm-hmm yep yeah it had
a bit of a bite at first which confused
me but then once I got into it it was
great I just pictured me in like the the
cantina on Tatooine and I'm just like
order one of these bad boys getting
turnt you know some intergalactic buds
Chewbacca would drink this see that I
bet you Baca is a drunk just wasted all
the time he actually speaks English but
it's it's like a it's like you need to
get your vocal cords to flap together